just mcdonald we saw quantum break at
our recent preview event it's Sydney
yeah what is quantum break how do you
actually play this game is essentially
but it is complicated by the fact that a
huge focus of the game is on these
powers and abilities you have which are
basically related to time manipulation
which is exactly the superhero [ __ ] that
it sounds like yeah initially when it
was first revealed the trailers had this
kind of like freeze time and walk
through it thing and we didn't we
weren't really sure about what the
gameplay actually was but you know being
a remedy game who are famous for Max
Payne and Alan Wake there was a lot of
shooting what are dodging what have
powers so it's really what you'd expect
from a remedy game so let's go through
some of the gut the the powers yes
okay the powers are really interesting
and what I like because we only played
it for a couple of hours but they gave
us a lot I mean this was the very
beginning of the game and they
introduced them to you like very rapidly
yeah but even so like after the first
two chapters we I knew there was more
coming yeah so that's a crazy insane
amount so there are powers that let you
say freeze enemies in a bubble and sort
of stack bullets into the bubble and
then when it releases it what comes out
and kills them instantly and then
there's powers that are just like I
don't want to get shot for a bunch of
time and you put it around yourself yeah
which is also really useful if you're
getting enemies running up to you
because it pushes them away yeah that's
really cool there's a probably the best
one I use which is one of the ones who
get a little laid up probably an hour
and hour and a half in is it's like a
massive force push excuse the Star Wars
reference where it's like you can charge
up basically like a force field that
shoots in the direction of an enemy and
knocks them back oh is this the one that
explodes yeah oh yeah that's a good one
I also really love the force - so you
can run into enemies and then sort of
push them back and then aim and it'll be
slow motion for those very mechs a
little bit be a little bit bullet time
of guns but that's not terribly
innovative this felt interesting because
if you just look at the fact that it's
you and twenty guys
you're quite outgunned and outmanned and
you're also not particularly powerful
you can't take a hell of a lot of shots
before you go down but um you definitely
felt like you had the edge or at least I
did with these different powers like
being able to dodge very quickly out of
the way when you're in a really bad spot
yeah I also found that I started playing
this game as more of a traditional cover
shooter so I usually stay in the one
place but that was kind of like not fun
and also I would die a lot because they
the military guys thank you very easily
so I found it's it was way more
effective to be aggressive with your
powers you know like runs the fray like
charged through everyone and have them
you know knocked off their feet and that
made it like more enjoyable to like
being able to defend yourself with a
bubble charge up a massive thing to
shoot an explosion in someone's
direction and stop them from attacking
you at the same time it was a great way
to deal with the massive grunts yeah
yeah yeah all right so another big part
about this game part of this game rather
is the story so they're pitching this
whole it's a game but it's a TV series
and when you play the game and effects
the TV series how does this actually
work just the other day about how you
play for an hour and a half and then you
sit there for twenty two minutes yeah
and watch a show but it actually relates
to a decision you've just made as the
villain which is a five minute segment
you play before the TV show episode
comes on which is a very significant
decision you need to make that's going
to affect the rest of the story yeah and
that's picked up in the live-action
which is quite cool yeah I shouldn't
mention that at the end of the first act
we played is swapped over to play so you
play the antagonist yeah and you make a
choice and so it just shows the
repercussions of that yeah so we picked
different one we did so the situation
was that a college had been this sort of
location for firefight and the villain
had to sort of decide how to deal with
that incident the first option was kill
all witnesses because it makes the supe
evil and obviously society wouldn't have
been on their side and they would have
been exposed for everything they were
doing because they were still witnesses
out there hadn't been killed that's the
one you chose that's the one I chose
because I was thinking about you know
Jack Joyce protagonist and sort of his
how he might you know win in the end
yes so the one on each choice because I
can't bring myself to kill all children
with having holstering decide to start
like a propaganda campaign basically
saying that all the crap that happened
and at the university it was Jack
Joyce's fault our hero and it frames him
as this horrible dude he becomes like
outcasted and it's a bad backlash for
the heroes for long term but you don't
get a bunch of people killed they get
killed in ads yeah so this actually it
affected the next act in a bigger way
than I expected it to so there was a bit
of puzzling and sort of you saved
someone from getting killed
and the person who I got in my act was
completely different from yours so I in
the episode that follows that decision
there was a girl and there is an
execution scene if you decide to kill
everyone and there is all there is a PR
and recording of a message
so she was absent from my game and you
could discover her body and kind of like
you know lament her death I got a
completely different character who was
helping me out it was like a taxi driver
it was kind of funny yeah in my version
it's like okay like the good guys have
taken a hit but the girl is alive and
she helps you out through the next
x2 I was very surprised by how they're
making the choice system work yeah
because I mean originally hearing about
it it's like even if I'm playing the
villains I want the heroes to win but
they've made it more complex than that
now yeah absolutely
each each option has really big pros and
cons yeah that's all for quantum break
for this preview but stay tuned against
part where we will have way more quantum
break coverage a breeze